so I thought I would start off by asking
both of you how he got involved the
project and also specifically what was
your emotional or intellectual
relationship with junior Tolkien there's
a couple years back I mean the journey
is quite long so when around 12 13 I
started reading his book and books and
this was the time when I was very
miserable I was quite alone and I was at
that time growing with other father and
I was being bullied and basically the I
was feeling like an outsider we had
moved and then the first book I think a
teacher game gave it to me I said I
think you're gonna like this and and
that became an escape and those stories
can became those friends that I was
seeking at the time and then fast
forward 30 late thirty years later I get
sent a script I mean that time the
script was quite different what you see
now but it's a story of friendship about
a young boy around age 12 being an
outsider growing without the father and
there's a certain or destiny that you
know by the at the time when I fell in
love with his stories this film or the
stories to making in the era and that's
how you know this is this odd friendship
with him that I feel and and you know
that's why then involved and then we
started writing and shaping and you know
making the film for me it's just being
in the arms of a storyteller I mean did
JR Tolkien who was just immensely
readable I've always loved children's
literature I mean not that this is
children's literature but and also the
the notion of illustrations and and and
obviously for me how music joins with
image so it was just kind of Wow on the
one hand on the other met Tomei and and
so enjoyed his work and and have so much
enjoyed our collaboration what changed
if anything for how you saw Tolkien
through the process of making this film
I mean well the image overall image I
mean I was growing in Finland so I have
actually have an American father who was
a member of the man persona when I was a
kid one as I got to know him as a
teenager actually used to attend these
screenings in New York where he lived
and he was very sick at this you know
old HOA took very much pride that still
walking with King with a cane to the
screening so actually I'm really honored
to be here it feels actually quite great
but as I was growing in Finland and at
that time the only thing you get is the
you know kind of the book when a boob
was published or and no good local
newspaper will tell the story about CS
Lewis and Oxford and he was smoking a
pipe and debating with Elle about elves
or Christianity and that's the story you
get and then you'd walk into this
history and now that's an orphan it's a
poor kid it's not a privileged Oxford
man there's actually a darkness he's
actually gone through a certain darkness
it's a story from darkness to light and
when you look at his illustrations that
I studied a lot I went to art school
when you look at illustrations they are
quite dark and they're kind of lines
they have a temper so you can feel that
he's processing with his early age
illustrations is processing the pain
that you know that we see here and I
think that was something there
revelation you feel that our case was
always a joyful fellow because you see
the interviews in the 60s done by BBC
but that's coming from a wisdom that
seen all this so that was kind of the
revelation for me about his story so I
had read that you eat that you'd work
together on the music for a year before
and before you even saw a first cut of
the film right is that correct
yeah I'd seen fragments but we got
together and started thinking and it was
it was a wonderful way to to present
ideas without that horrible kind of
looming Friday afternoon where things
had to be done or whatever so we got to
know each other I think really well and
that was that was a wonderful thing
there's a wonderful anecdote so
basically as you saw the shoot was hell
you know was heavy it was basically I
was told you I totally burned out and I
told my editor I don't want to see any
material in like a month I need to
recover so we rented a house here with
my wife then I emailed Tom saying hey I
might come up over to a cup of coffee
this tell us a lot about
you know say hi oh great you have any
material let's start working and I'm the
editor like oh Tom would love to work
and see something so I have to have to
go to edit and patch a couple scenes
together to show like the style and the
feel and then ended up actually working
his studio for four days and that's how
I fell in love with this man because the
passion like when can I start even
though it was three months before we you
know finished a cut wait this is just
fun to do that maybe the best part of
all this for me is just what you get to
share with someone moment to moment and
day to day and and you learn about taste
you learn about you know if if if ideas
that we have we're gonna stick you know
and someone said you know we're always
ready to make a movie once we're all
done because now we trust each other in
earnest but I think Damai and i trust
each other along the way probably
because we had a bit of a bit more time
and noticed in the film is there's
really kind of three visual styles
through the film was when I can you
describe those and maybe talk to talk to
us about your thinking behind that
well the key was his illustrations so
that's putting it out I know last a lot
the first thing when you read about his
of course read everything about him and
listen to every interview met among goes
around talking experts and the
difficulty with talking experts is that
one person will say this and the other
person will contradict it because of
course there's always a filter that
that's their personality that filters or
analyzes it so everyone thinks that they
are the right approach so as an artist
when you're making a biopic you have to
find this is my interpretation this is
the voice I hear through through
everything and the key for me was the
illustrations kind of the colors he uses
the color palette and a said kind of the
depth and the stories he's trying to
tell as a very young boy and or a young
man and so it felt like okay there's
darkness but then this Edith which has
light so we talked a lot with us in the
team us in talking for Lassa Frank that
Edith is kind of the warm light in his
darkness since earlier so who played a
lot like basically the light coming more
and more into the story he when he when
he loses the Shire of course that's true
how he felt that's the emotion if
that he left from the Shire from English
countryside into Birmingham which is
called black England I believe is the
phrase I was a feeling kind of entering
this kind of a darker place so if you
look at the wallpaper it misses walking
at their darker so everything there in
the colors palette it's a bit dark
slowly slowly
Edith kind of brings that light into it
and then of course war where the ground
Montgomery's fantastic our production
designer because the world were one buff
and he know that one interesting thing
the world were one camera equipment
couldn't handle rain plus they're always
black and white so we don't see what it
actually looks like and song which is
next to a river what the chemicals when
they're going in the air or the
chemicals when the water oxide will make
the water red the mist will be different
colors it's almost like even the 70s
like you know just you know just these
colors are seeing and so we use that as
an element of kind of visualizing his
image of it's not his Mordor but it's
kind of a first step or first idea of
this ruthless world colorful world
so kind of there were different elements
that I can took from his illustrations
or from his truth to like feelings how I
felt well I want to thank you both for
being here and thank you all for coming